bring in Tom Verducci the great baseball
writer for Sports Illustrated works for
MLB Network he'll join Bob Costas and
Jim kaat to call tonight's Indians at
Red Sox game at 7 p.m. on MLB Network
Tom's book is the Cubs way it's
available in stores everywhere and Tom
kind enough to join me here on the show
what do you think Tom are you going to
get the first Steve Bartman interview I
think for full closure he has to appear
on Curb Your Enthusiasm you know that
tide has turned right I mean that's
literally I think like a lot of people I
made a run apartment over the years he's
kept a low profile good for him but I
think there does come a time here where
people just want to hear his voice and
see his face and just tell him you know
or at least have the feeling it's all
forgiven it wasn't your fault buddy
we've moved on let's all move on what
have your experience been like trying to
get Steve Bartman to do an interview
well basically go through his
representative he's an attorney in
Chicago very nice guy you know I passed
a long quest I did one for my book and
thought I could get him for the book
just to have him quoted without having
his face out there because I think he
likes being quote unquote anonymous
around going around in life so but he's
been very gracious he's turned out many
other opportunities to I don't even want
to say make a buck on it but profit at
least by His image and itchy stir
everybody tells me he's the kind of guy
who is the typical die-hard Cubs fan you
know Liz Brie's Cubs baseball and that
was not an easy moment for him so I I
think all of us want to move on but all
of us want this guy to to inside the
Cubs the way any fan could enjoy a cub
at the Cubs would not have to be so
anonymous it's hard to juxtapose calm
staying anonymous and still living in
Chicago it surprised you that he stayed
in Chicago after all this yeah I mean
especially being a Cubs fan I'm sure you
know he'd want to go to the ballpark and
things like that hang out the Cubby Bear
so yeah it does surprise me a little bit
there had been rumors that he'd gone
overseas immediately after that um
listen I I know that that night and the
next day after that game in 2003 the
media which is camped out all over his
street
that must have been a scary proposition
and I can understand why someone would
just want to go quote-unquote into
hiding because you know if you're just
an ordinary civilian you are not used to
that kind of life so I don't blame them
at all for essentially going underground
for all these years talking to Tom
Verducci senior writer Sports
Illustrated works they will be network
as well joining me here on the Dan
Patrick show Tom the Dodgers probably
didn't need you Darvish but how much
better did they get with Yu Darvish I
actually argue that they did need him
because he listens they're like the 84
Tigers this year just completely boat
racing they're linked that doesn't mean
they can do the same in the postseason
and when I looked at the matchups
potential matchups in the postseason
environment I'm talking about starting
pitching you go against Cubs or against
the Nationals
you don't win any of the starting
pitching matchups beyond Kershaw getting
the ball and that's assuming Kershaw
comes back and it's the same pitcher
after missing for six weeks with this
back injury looks like no there's an
incredibly deep offensively the bench is
terrific their bullpen is very deep but
you still have to at least play the
first five to six innings of the game
even with the other team and they were
in danger of not doing that without
another starting pitcher I mean you saw
that happened last year right I mean
they tried to get by with captain by Ada
and Julio Reyes and they were both out
of games early the Oriskany game four
against the Cubs was the one that really
turned that series so now I think
they're more of a sure thing to get
through the playoffs with a guy who's
going to give them I think at least six
stable innings yeah you go back a couple
years ago to with Game three of the LDS
panther roll Brett Anderson out there
now they have some depth at their
pitching staff with Darvish on the
mountain do you think Tom he's a better
picture in LA than what he showed in the
first half plus of the season in Texas I
did I definitely do I mean all his
metrics are pretty much where they
should be in terms of velocity and
things like that to selection and by the
way having Darvish there also allows
them to stay away from this fatal
mistake they seem to be doing the
postseason all the time by pitching
Kershaw short rest you know it hasn't
worked out well in these playoffs night
scenarios so now they can use Hill &
wood behind Darvish and curse off their
one but listen I think garbage has been
a
goodbye rumors of being on the market
for this month I really do it happens to
some people I thought it happened to Roy
Halladay it happened a little bit to Jon
Lester you know people go up there and
Scout the guy just want to look at stuff
and I know he got absolutely bombed by
the by the Marlins last week in Texas
the 10 run game I spoke with the Marlins
players they were actually a little
ticked off that people are simulating
that he was tipping his pitches they
said absolutely not
and they said the Darvish was just in
the middle of a play throughout the game
simple as that
I think that's typically not him so I do
think the environment of having his name
out there on a market for a guy who's
never been traded I think it did affect
him but stuff wise especially especially
transitioning to the National League I
love taking pictures from the AL gone to
the NL with a complete automatic bailout
spot in the ninth spot in a lineup
really affect how you pitch a while but
I think there'll be a lot better in LA
Nationals get Brandon Kinsler a couple
other relievers as well their bullpen
was I think the worst of baseball prior
to these deals did they solve those
bullpen problems this week well they're
better how much sure they're completely
solved I mean the run yesterday was
definitely on Phillies pitching and
especially relief pitchers who can miss
Brett homeruns have totally changed this
game I mean there's so many home runs in
the game today that nobody was out there
in the market shopping for bats
I can't remember a trade deadline where
that happened I mean the position
players traded were Adam Rosales utility
infielder and Tim Beckham shortstop and
I'm still trying to figure out why the
Orioles traded for him but anyway it was
all about getting power arms there's
enough of them in the game but really
loading up on power arms the top seven
bullpen in Major League Baseball all
added relief pitchers in July that's
where the game that and you saw last
year the postseason with Cleveland the
way they could just really hold a game
from the sixth inning on with keeping
the ball out of play so kids lured to me
is a good addition because they simply
needed better more reliable arms but
he's a ground ball pitcher he's not a
strikeout pitcher the ball's going to be
play against him i still don't think
they match up against the dodgers and
they could certainly prove me wrong but
at least they have address there the
biggest weakness but I don't think
they've solved it Red Sox Yankees both
you know feels like it's 15 years ago
our
race in the American League East between
those two teams Addison Reed Sonny gray
which one of these teams improve the
most you think at the deadline well I
think the Yankees because you have to
also look at the additions that came
Liam Fraser and Robertson I mean you
talk about strikeout pitchers they have
five of the top 18 relievers in baseball
that comes to strikeout rate it's just
ridiculous there's never been a bullpen
like this that keeps the ball out of
play and now I think gray is that
missing piece for the Yankees because
now they can go San Marino gray Sabathia
Tanaka that's good enough to win the
World Series I think it I wouldn't have
said that earlier I didn't think they
have enough starting pitching to win the
World Series now I think right now
they're a better keeping of the Red Sox
I do like the Addison Reed addition but
to me I mean anybody who's 35 and under
has never seen the big spectacle in
baseball and that's Yankees against the
Dodgers in the World Series and
yesterday brought us closer to seeing
that for the first time I'm in the
biggest World Series audience in history
78 World Series Yankees Dodgers 40 4.2
million people not going to get to that
another but it just goes to tell you
when you get New York in LA Dodgers
Yankees with the Cubs winning the World
Series there's nothing bigger at
baseball yesterday move this a step
closer to getting that now of course I
mean anything could happen to postseason
that's the usual caveat but at least
those two teams to me where the biggest
winners on deadline day has a David
Price gotten upset at you recently
because you started this time you know
you you've got the rock going down the
mountain later well it is you criticize
David Price and he all of a sudden
became very sensitive to all forms of
criticism yeah in like that I think that
was a David Ortiz home running it off
and fly off and I was working for TPS
and mentioned the fact that Ortiz was
sitting on that pitch and yeah he didn't
like that he's never said anything to my
face it's just a shame that for the Red
Sox this is still a lingering issue I
mean they don't need anything like this
where it's player-created right I mean
the thing to do if you don't like what
somebody says I have listened I think
David got every reason to be mad at
Dennis Eckersley I could disagree with
him but he has a right to do that but
the way you handle it is you pull the
man aside and you talk to him one-on-one
like a man
you don't stand up in front of your
teammate so you can look like the top
guy in front of your own guys and air
out a Hall of Fame pitcher you handle it
like a man one-on-one in private and he
chose not to do that and that's why it's
a public issue it would have been a
private issue before but now it's a
public issue and it's part of the dirty
laundry the whole Red Sox team because
we're still talking about it right and
it probably won't go away and every time
he pitches when he comes back it will be
talked about and I think it's a shame
that the entire team now has to carry
that baggage always great to catch up
with you Tom I appreciate the time you
got it thanks for having me best on
Verducci senior baseball writer Sports
Illustrated and I'll be network he'll
join Bob Costas Jim kaat to call
tonight's Indians at Red Sox game 7 p.m.
on Emily networks lost Tom's book I read
it's terrific the Cubs away it's
available in stores everywhere the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience